hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in Aleister McIntyre's piece plain
persons and moral philosophy just by the
very title alone you've got two
important
Concepts or Notions or realities that
are being juxtaposed to each other and
one of the things that McIntyre is doing
in this piece is asking a set of closely
connected guiding questions answering
which is the goal of the piece and
McIntyre you know is going to present
his point of view on this through a kind
of extended argument which by the way
jibes with his very important text after
virtue which is written before this so
he's asking a few really important
questions the first is the verse the
very first sentence of the piece what is
the relationship between the moral
philosopher's judgments about the life
of practice and and the everyday plain
person's moral questions and judgments
and he points about moral philosophers
are of course themselves in most of
their lives everyday plain persons but
on some views what they do and judge as
a moral philosopher is very different
from what they do and judge as a plain
person so a plain person is a broader
category right and then moral
philosophers or ethicists or however you
want to call them people who are doing
this in a structured academically
informed perhaps even academically
housed way are a weird kind of outlier
and they're really interested in
theories and arguments and you know the
whole history of ideas perhaps whereas
ordinary every day playing persons not
quite so much
now at the same time if we want those
everyday playing persons to be good
people or if they want to be good people
well
maybe they actually need to like look at
the connection or you know take some
ideas on from moral philosophy so this
leads to the second question and
McIntyre frames it very early on
he says the question to which this
lecture is addressed is
just how much of a moral philosopher
does the plain person need to become so
you know he's already willingly
admitting that he is presupposing some
answer to this which is not to to no
extent right the question is all right
so we don't need to turn every single
person into a professional ethicist you
know studying for hours each day or
something like that but they do need to
be informed at least to some degree by
moral philosophy in in certain ways
right and before we look directly at his
explicit answer to this
we should you know think about what he
stresses along the way
and so he says that
um
we need to focus on what he calls the
unity of a life because people do stop
to ask themselves every once in a while
am I actually like going the right way
or to you know paraphrase something from
a comedy skit that is now turned into a
meme are we the baddies are we doing the
wrong thing you know where do we fit in
ordinary people don't always engage in
you know complex moral judgments but
sooner or later they do have to ask
these questions have I gone the wrong
way am I going the right way the goods
that I have selected as worthy of
pursuing and prioritizing did I make the
right choices or you know this is where
like midlife or existential crises often
come up
did I bet on the wrong horse and now can
I get off on another one or am I stuck
here right so he he tells us that you
know Ordinary People do come to think
about these sorts of matters right and
typically we're doing that through what
he calls dramatic narratives
um and he says that the plain person
responds to the sort of claims that
rival Goods make not through explicit
arguments so much A lot of these can
play a part right you can read something
and be like oh wow
um this is actually quite helpful but
instead they shape their life in one way
rather than another when from time to
time the plain person retrospectively
examines what his or her life amounts to
as a whole often with a view to choice
between alternative Futures
characteristically what they're asking
is to what conception of My overall good
if I so far committed myself do I have
reason to put it into question now they
don't usually formulate it in those
words uh thinking about this but we do
so through stories
we think about other people's stories
people that we're close to people that
we know we were like oh I don't want to
turn out like Uncle Ralph over here
right or Aunt Betty over here they've
you know managed to mess their life up
maybe I can draw some lessons from that
why did their marriage fall apart why
did they end up having a string of uh uh
you know the opposite of success at work
getting fired from job after job and
never building a useful career how did
they end up losing their house through
bad financial
um transactions and risk assessment and
stuff like that so sometimes we're we're
looking at other people's mistakes
sometimes we're looking at other
people's successes we think about our
own life we draw upon our culture and in
doing so we use narratives dramatic
narratives to make sense of these things
and he brings up a few things this is
not an exhaustive list of what we could
derive from this but one of them is
realizing what happens what are the
marks he calls it but we could also call
it consequences of somebody who's
developing a bad character which could
be other people but could be us as well
he says one of the things we most need
to learn first from narrative and then
from theory is that it's one of the
marks of Someone Who develops bad
character that as it develops
she or he becomes progressively less and
less able to understand what it is that
she or he has mislearned and how it was
that she he or she fell into error part
of the Badness of bad character is
intellectual blindness on moral
questions now the flip side of this is
that we have to have some sort of
account of these three things that he's
really stressing here Goods the things
that we consider valuable desirable that
we have to you know prioritize because
we can't actually have it all we have to
decide what we're going to sacrifice
what we're going to pursue rules you
know principles you can call them you
could call them whatever you want
Proverbs adages things that tell us what
we ought to do
and you know generally we follow them
there may be exceptions and then virtues
the traits of character like you know
honesty or Justice or courage or
temperateness that we need in order not
just to have a good character but even
to understand our relationship with
goods and rules and we can have a
a life that progressively develops and
integrates these or it can be one which
is quite discordant these are both
possibilities for us and so you know
moral philosophy can help out with this
to some extent now a little bit later
he's going to finally like raise the
question in a explicit way he says we
can now say something more not only
about how much
of a moral philosopher the plain person
has to be but also about what kind of a
moral philosopher the plain person has
to be and how this may differ from
situation to situation
so how much do they need
he says the plain person needs as much
of a theory as will enable him or her to
do two things
one of these is to as he says Identify a
significant Alternatives which now
confront her or him so being able to
figure out well what kind of a situation
am I actually in and what's at stake
what you know if I go this way uh what
am I actually choosing if I go this way
what am I choosing uh and you know
rejecting over here because you can't
necessarily have all of it
so being able to figure out what you're
actually doing and what is up for
discussion or up for Choice that's one
thing
that's future oriented right I mean you
might say as well as of the present but
it's the present moving into the future
the other has to do with the past
and this is very interesting
this is a characteristic of McIntyre's
point of view about what a good moral
theory
ought to enable us to do
so he says it also enables us to
understand
why and how it was in the past that she
or he the plain person did or did not
make mistakes in acting in one way
rather than another so
theories allow us a sort of
retrospective which is part of how we
can actually have a dramatic narrative a
narrative includes our past and we can
say oh
wow you know I actually made good
decisions over here I I didn't quite
realize what I was doing at the time but
thank goodness that I did or we can say
oh man I bought into this perspective
this set of uh wrong priorities and I
really screwed things up and screwed
myself up in the process why don't I
have Temperance because I wanted to
party so much back then I thought
partying was a great thing and you know
turns out I should have been doing this
and this and this instead if I'd wanted
to make progress and we could go on and
on with all sorts of cool examples of
that but this is what McIntyre takes
moral theories when they're actually
being used by the Plain person as
enabling us to do these are their
functions right
so he goes on and he says that there's
another really important consideration
this need may not be me may not be met
not only if the plain person is
insufficiently a theorist right they
don't want to think about things they
just want to react they just want to
take what their culture tells them or
some Authority
um but also if the theory which is made
available to her him even if true an
adequate theory is stated in too much
abstraction from the specificities and
particularities of her or his historical
and autobiographical situation that's a
very long-winded way of saying it's got
to be relatable you got to have a moral
theory that you can take and use as a
lens in your own life there's got to be
some traction some interaction and so
here he says something really quite
interesting this is why we would not
meet the Practical needs of contemporary
plain persons by simply providing them
with copies of the Nick can ethics and
if Aquinas is commentary or even of the
uh Prima sukunde of the Soma theologia
now why so he says well what people
would lack is a capacity for reading or
hearing what is written in the text is
providing answers to their own
specific and particular questions
these texts may be theoretically
powerful but remain practically idle
they don't do work for us until we learn
how to read them
so you know in an ethics class for
example which is one of the the few
places where most people who are at
least you know in SEC post-secondary
education are going to encounter moral
theories in a really robust way
you know we're not doing our students
any favors if we you know give them
Aristotle's Nick and McCain ethics and
say hey just read this it's going to fix
your life man check it out you know we
have to do the work of Building Bridges
Building Bridges between the universal
and Abstract over here what Aristotle is
talking about and everyday life by plain
persons who are not philosophy Majors
right same thing if we're doing ethics
training we must show how these things
how these theories actually play out in
real people's lives with genuine
examples that they can relate to or else
we're kind of condemning them to not
getting it right so not just the right
sort of theory but also the framing is
really important as well according to
Mcintyre and that is in fact what he did
in his own teaching in his own classes
and in much of his writings as well
right so he goes on
and he says you know somebody could
raise some objections to what I'm saying
here and he says um let's consider these
the first might Begin by pointing out
that many plain persons have done just
fine morally without ever encountering
philosophy this seems to be an empirical
fact right there's actually we can find
this in some moral theory Saint
Augustine for example in his ncaridian
will say or it might be on Christian
doctrine that there are old women who
have never they're illiterate they've
never read a bit of theology they don't
even read scripture and yet they know
more about faith hope and charity three
important virtues than many Bishops do
right there's a lot of people who do
pretty good like he says
with the moral resources afforded by
sound plain practical teaching the call
cultivation of the virtues and
instructed conscience what need is there
for philosophy you know we could say
well the philosophers over here they do
their thing it's a you know elitist
minority thing and then you know plain
persons over here if they've got a good
healthy culture they don't need all that
stuff and now that's assuming that they
actually have a good healthy culture
that they belong to which is kind of a
shaky assumption there but he goes on
and he says that
um I'm not claiming that the plain
person needs to become anything like a
professional theorist what I'm saying is
that the practice of the moral life by
plain persons always presupposes the
truth of some particular theoretical
standpoint and when confronted by rival
claims to his or her moral allegiance to
the plain person's practical choices
will be a choice between theoretical
standpoints so he gives it a prime
example in our own Society common plain
persons who've never heard of John
Stuart Mill offer as the deliverances of
what they take to be their Common Sense
maxims of hedonistic utilitarianism you
don't actually need to like know the
theory in order to reflect it to embody
it to act upon it and so wouldn't it be
useful to know what the hell you're
doing right what theories you're
actually committed to
now there's a second objection which is
quite a bit more interesting you know
McIntyre is claiming that we're all as
plain persons what he calls
proto-aristotelians as opposed to you
know
um let's call it endorsers and embodiers
of other moral theories
um
Aristotle says bad stuff about playing
persons Aristotle is in the grease of
his own time writing to and for the
elites he looks down upon ordinary
people people who have to work with
their hands for example women slaves all
sorts of people and as a matter of fact
just about everybody watching this would
be considered by Aristotle a barbarian
and not worthy of talking to as well
um but Eric so so you know
McIntyre says that's quite true right
um but here's the thing Aristotle has no
worthwhile arguments to support these
exclusions and the domestic
aristotelianism of for example a Jacques
mariten or Eve Simone rightly ignored
them and so do I you know it's it's sort
of like saying yeah that was that's a
point you can make but it's not a useful
Point aristotelianism has moved on and
left some of the mistakes of Aristotle
behind so not really much of an
objection so you know what do we have
here the plain person doesn't need to
become a academic philosopher they don't
even have to like devote three hours a
day to studying academic philosophy but
there has to be something analogous to a
process of training and development and
you know learning from your mistakes and
developing a narrative and in order to
do that you got to get your theory from
somewhere so the plain person does if
they want to be successful
they need to become a bit of a moral
philosopher at the right times you know
for the right reasons this sounds rather
Aristotelian too doesn't it if you know
your Aristotle and so this is the answer
that McIntyre gives to this question I
think it's clear here just to wrap up
that McIntyre also thinks that you know
the wrong kind of academic study or
study on your own of Ethics could
actually screw you up but done well done
as part of a community part of a
tradition that is properly informed that
has cultivated the virtues that does
have a right conception of the goods
that understands the rules that need to
be in place and that need to be you know
uh qualified that is going to be
incredibly helpful for plain persons so
we don't want to dismiss moral
philosophy altogether right we want to
have the right kind and the right
presentation or engagement with it